[Music]
if you were trying to get away with a
crime and like have a false ID what
would be in kind of your tactics and I
blamed it on stupid little baby man oh
that's a good tactic wait so like if you
wanted to create it like if someone
they're like show me your ID and you
needed backup like I'll make love in
type of thing we're trying to steal
still identity he's like what would you
do I my name is Tim Chong Chong whoa
whoa one one more Chong and that's
racist dude my name is Casey Chan Casey
oh do you mean like where I would get it
like if I want to go down to like I
don't understand the scenario your dude
made a fake ID using Robert De Niro's I
doesn't show a picture of those guys who
thinks he looks like Robert De Niro what
do you because he does this all the time
well he's Romanian and I will say that
he used a younger younger ish version
dude he was hot when he was young he's
that he's probably about 45 in this
picture the kid knows young young but
like younger than years now people in
other countries when they look at like
when you have like the countries that
have like I don't say play but sometimes
they say the most sometimes you get like
a Russian kid that's like oh I want to
be or like a little Russian girl that's
I want to be Beyonce so they do
everything they get like this thing that
makes her skin darker and they get all
this plastic surgery and they're just
like my whole life is now them mmm I
don't see that happening in America yeah
I don't know what this guy looks like
but I think Robert DeNiro like he like
kind of looks a little similar to him
and so he's like yeah sure this guy but
he uses Robert De Niro's actual name on
the ID like he's like I'm this guy where
I've been Dino's picture and then has
Robert De Niro's name on it maybe you
didn't know he was famous so he was like
American Robin hobb so I probably did
that one thing that like you know that
app that you post picture yourself they
show you who you look like
Oh
yeah even though it was perfect then on
their ideas they have to show like their
who their mom and dad are like so they
have like one mom and dad so you listed
as mamma's Madonna oh my god his dad is
Anthony how much like fraudulent ideas
do they have that you have to put your
parents on the Hyades back in the day
when you announce yourself you lie all
son of this I know like in Game of
Thrones days are like the seventies when
you guys are what seventies in the
discotheque here yeah while we were
rolling on [ __ ] acid and [ __ ] right
yeah Leggett Oh son of delegate oh he
put Madonna who is younger than Robert
De Niro I give this guy doesn't know who
these people are and then he put just a
random person named Anthony as his
father yeah
what was the crime so he got caught with
thirteen hundred pills of ecstasy okay
except intend to sell yeah some
countries that's death Oh selling drugs
in doing drugs he was just he was jailed
for nine years
whoa the fraud yeah he beat he used the
ID card to take out bank loans though so
the bank was like yeah
what really holy [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] you
doing here Robert you give him any loan
he wants but he gave the address for
Robert Narrows being the cemetery and
that's ultimately how they found out
you're like no one lives here
dead people live get loans though that's
so funny he passed because you watch it
every time every time they try to like
question him you go are you talking what
bank is this oh this is I need to go get
some loans in this place Romania
Romanian name is soren Bulgaria he's 53
and yeah his is your picture of this
there's no picture of him I know I wish
there was how'd you know he looks like
in though I am guessing that he looks
like him because otherwise how would you
as a bank like maybe you know how when
they ask for like second proof of I
gotta fication he just hands on like
heat or something yeah Meet the Fockers
in DVD yeah meet the part where he goes
I have nipples
and they were like oh my god that's so
down yeah and so he got he got caught
with a bunch of ecstasy pills and he had
1,300 ecstasy pills and then 15 grams of
ecstasy pill fragments at his residence
and then he was arrested and he'll be
held in detention on suspicion of drug
trafficking for a period of 30 days this
road trafficking wasn't a drug I'm such
a [ __ ] law-abiding citizen I get
scared with doing any of that stuff so
if I had the opportunity as like a
teenager to have a day they did a lot of
stuff ha
well not not to that extent but I'm
gonna tell you what just even getting
like a fake ID I don't think I could
ever do that [ __ ]
so yeah I'm alive we're on high school
did you guys have like so in high school
like we would have IDs that were passed
down right like we would have like a
friend's older brother or older cousin
that like this person graduated and he
knows how hard is to get cigarettes and
beer or whatever so they would just pass
it down and then you would just keep
passing it down and be like one person
that was like you used over and over
again and we couldn't wait to share ID
like stick with like Asian people pass
me about yeah are you saying they all
look the same
yeah that's what I heard that's one of
the perks one of the perks of being us
yeah you know no one looks like me
that's the one benefit you know I think
we look like but to them to the cat's
off yeah yeah them liquor salesman clubs
and look at him they're like huh okay I
did fake my ID one time but I was really
bad at it because I also didn't want to
go and like lick the law too bad but I
was turning 21 in three months
but it was but during the summer because
my birthday's in the fall
well during the summer everyone was
already 21 so they were all going out
and I felt super left out so I took my
actual ID and it's in red marking on the
California idea it has your birthday so
I took a red no it's some stupidest [ __ ]
and I made mine's 1102 86 so 86 and
so I put I do know my real ID [ __ ] you
this 2007 okay so I made the one zero
with a pen so it looked like it was
January 2nd and I felt like it looked
pretty good but the guy at the club like
he examined it too hard he's like he's
like to handwrite your ID I was like did
I my dude no did you get in no damn it I
can beat that cuz one time I went to
Vegas it wasn't me being dumb though I
went to Vegas with a group of guys and I
didn't know half of them and one [ __ ]
dumb ass kid he's like you he wasn't
legal but he's like don't ship I got a
fake ID we're good we're good I figured
it wasn't legal like to go to Vegas on
the 21 so we [ __ ] were halfway to
Vegas and then I'm like I don't know who
was looking at his ID but we're like
dude this ID says you're 20 whale-like
wait a second breath so like we were in
Vegas gonna clubs and [ __ ]
and he was just off by yourself walking
around baby because he's getting carded
he goes I got I got it no I you mean get
the [ __ ] up yeah oh and here's what's
funny about this this [ __ ] this group
of guys I went with they were very they
were all about like lying about people
they had had sex with like it was like
their thing
it was so weird it was so weird bro
because they're virgins no like so the
whole time were there this whole little
goof was like all right yeah we all go
get some [ __ ] bogus biz blah blah
looking around Vegas trying to get
numbers and this one the 20 year old at
one point he's like he's again I I went
I just I told me I just got this
fine-ass girls number like oh yeah all
right let me see it right
and for some reason like he said she
wrote it down so I threw it away like
she wasn't thank you Bo
and then it was also a [ __ ] like that
the whole weekend and then so one time
how annoying yeah bro okay so and one
time so and I had been hanging out with
some other Vegas friend like a friend of
mine in Vegas like a homegirl and then
one of the guys from the group picked me
up to go join the group and he's like he
said but when we head back to the hotel
I told them that you [ __ ] that girl
you hanging out with alright I was like
what why he's like oh thank you
so then we we get back after a night of
clubbing when 20 ruble guy was in the
like chillin by himself we get back to
the room he's a [ __ ] chillin in the
robe in the in the hotel by himself
and he's like and and he's like oh yeah
no I had some had some girls over here
and and even the guy that picked me up
the car he was like yeah nah he had some
business room so we gotta leave em alone
so I get there get into the room there's
like a bathtub that's filled with water
there's like empty [ __ ] like lotion
bottles you use can't use condoms
loading in the bathtub and I'm like
everybody else man like gonna clean this
up he's like man you had two girls here
that's crazy I'm like oh who [ __ ] in a
bathtub and it's like take my car my
throat in the water it was all so stupid
but then he gets to walk there and he's
picking up the condom he's a concern
such a [ __ ] player yeah I know it was
look dummies [ __ ] and I got his friends
playing to it to it are you such a
[ __ ] place - I do - probably why were
you hanging out with the man look I went
the question I went with okay so this
group of guys specifically action about
Eric 84 I knew one guy this guy and he
was like we're going to Vegas it should
be fun we got a suite you should come
with us and I was like I don't wanna go
along because I don't know these guys so
I hit up the superego head of area you
want to come with me he's like yeah all
right so we went with these [ __ ] guys
I mean hey like two weeks into the trip
were like we gotta get the [ __ ] it was
two weeks long days two days they stayed
four days we have to have to do it
eighteen-year-old ballers dude two weeks
in Vegas [ __ ] I kind of want to stick
around longer just see how crazy how
much crazy lies get yeah I'm sure was
just a bunch of just Shanae and there's
stupid lies that fool was like I got
this under control it's like not Dawg
you're only [ __ ] twenty years you
still can't hang with us makes no sense
we've all had some seriously
embarrassing friends well not that
embarrassed at twenty though no
definitely at 20 I had embarrassing ass
like my boyfriend at that time his
friends we would go to Vegas and they
would like light cigars but they weren't
old enough to like do anything so they
but except for buy cigars so they'd be
like in Vegas with suits on yeah that's
because they saw they saw swingers
yeah but Tim's friends like purposely go
to Urgent Care and come out with the
moms like the moms like oh yeah then
they get a cascade they [ __ ] barrier
like he was such a player man he died
anyway
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]